booster shots are one step closer to
getting into the arms of millions of
americans a food and drug administration
advisory panel recommended on friday a
second shot of johnson and johnson's
covid 19 vaccine for emergency use the
recommendation comes one day after the
panel approved a third shot of the
moderna vaccine for seniors and for
those adults said to be at high risk the
panel is still ironing out a strategy
that will allow americans to mix and
match different vaccine brands
potentially at the same time vaccine
mandates and requirements to show
vaccine status continue to come under
attack
michael george is here with the latest
michael good morning jeff good morning
this unanimous approval means we're one
step closer to booster shots being
approved for all three vaccines and this
comes as the country is seeing ninety
thousand new infections and roughly two
thousand deaths per day
in minnesota a shortage of step down and
long-term care workers and beds has
rippled into hospitals where hundreds of
patients have nowhere to go
the unvaccinated the governor warns risk
not having a hospital bed if they get
sick if we are unwilling to do the
things necessary to slow the spread of
covet that will be exacerbated until you
reach crisis situations like the state
of alaska the state of montana the state
of idaho ended up in where they have to
make the horrific decisions of telling
some people they can't come in nearly 34
percent of people in the u.s currently
eligible to get a vaccine haven't done
that making herd immunity impossible in
this country yet
some efforts to mandate vaccines
continue to meet with resistance some of
chicago's police are among them if you
ignore
a directive of your supervisor or worse
a direct order that's that's lawfully
given
you're going to destroy your career
yesterday evening the head of the police
union was ordered by a judge to stop
making social media posts that encourage
officers to stay unvaccinated
and in san francisco nearly 200 officers
have applied for religious or medical
exemptions rather than take a shot
there legal experts say they're likely
on the wrong side of the law you're
dealing with the general goodwill of the
public public health for an individual
to step back and say my personal beliefs
should trump the public need to be safe
in a public area i think that's just a
very difficult battle
and booster shots for fisa recipients
are already available for people 65 and
older and for at-risk groups and for
people who got the johnson and johnson
number dina shots the fda and cdc will
likely decide next week whether to fully
approve boosters and who should get them
well they have a recommendation on mix
and match that is being considered and
there was a study that came out from the
national institutes of health that
showed that mixing and matching is
effective it actually found that if you
got the johnson and johnson shot you're
better off switching to pfizer modern
for your second shot
all right michael george thank you so
much